- Moi, j'ai eu la chance
d'être encore là, en ce moment,
pour vous parler.
- Cet adolescent est
reconnaissant d'être encore
en vie. Il y a moi,
il a fait l'objet d'un complot
pour meurtre de la part
de quatre élèves de son école
secondaire de Montréal.
- Après ça, ça va être une étape
de me reconstruire avec les gens
autour, donc comment est-
ce que je réintègre les cercles
sociaux, comment est-ce que
je vais gérer mes relations
humaines, ça va surtout être
ça qui va prendre du temps.
- L'été dernier, quatre jeunes
de 15 ans de son école décident
de comploter pour le tuer.
Inspiré par la tuerie
bine en 1999,
aux États-Unis, le groupe
planifiera aussi de reproduire
une tuerie de masse
en surprenant des élèvesen clasr
sera déjoué par le SPVM
dès la rentrée scolaire.
- Le 5 septembre, on recoit
un appel. La police a
des raisons de croire qu'il y a
des menaces envers notre fils.
- Questionnée par les policiers,
l'une des quatres complices
est passée aux aveux mettant
un terme à l'exécution du plan.
échanges textes
présentés en preuves, tout était
prévu pour faire un massacre.
- Et c'est à glacer le sang
de voir tout ce plan-là,
minute par minute.
- Deux des quatres
accusés ont reçu des peines
de 12 et 15 mois de probation
aujourd'hui, après avoir plaidé
coupable à des accusations
de menaces de mort et complot
de voies de fait g
Ils devront également présenter
des lettres d'excuses à tous
les élèves de l'école visée.
Me JOANIE TRUDEL procureure DPCP
- On souhaite que les jeunes
prennent leurs responsabilités,
également comprennent ce qu'ils
ont posé comme gestes, l'impact
de ces gestes-là, notamment
sur les victimes.
Me MATHIEU FARAZANDEH, avocat
des deux adolescents accusés- D,
ici, il y a des profonds regrets
du côté de mes clients,
il y a eu une remition
qui a eu lieu.
- Le père de l'adolescent pense
aux parents de Ulvade, au Texas,
qui n'ont pas eu la chance que
la police intervienne à temps.
- Il est vivant parce que
ça a échoué. On est contents du
processus. Mais on se transpose
aux parents là-bas avec
une situation qui est irréelle.
J'ai la télé dans mon bureau
pour mon travail aussi, là.
À toutes les fois, là, ça vient
me faire cette espèce
pression ici, là.
On revit le choc.
- Les deux autres
dans le complot seront cités
à procès en octobre prochain.
En attendant, la petite famille
devra faire preuve de courage
jusqu'à la fin des procédures
judiciaires.
Ici Pascal Robidas,
Radio-Canada, Mon